hello everyone i'm alana welcome to my
channel where today we are recording my
second q a
of the month i now do two every month um
one that is to answer all the gaming
related questions that i get and one
that is to answer everything else that i
get because i realize they're kind of
different audiences and sometimes when i
have a gaming headline for the q a
people are like why did you talk about
makeup
but then there's also definitely an
audience that prefers all of the other
topics as well so i've split them into
two if you want to ask questions for
either of the next two q a's the next
one will be a gaming one um in a couple
of weeks you can leave them in the
comments below also whatever and i will
still always just pull them from the
last one easy peasy zatras ii
asked hey alana i know you're into
sneakers and i just bought myself a
flashy pair for the first time ever
serious question do you ever preferred a
method for tying the laces or should i
just stick with the big floppy post that
my parents taught me
um i mean there are a lot of opinions on
how you're supposed to lace your shoes
in sneaker culture and i'm certainly not
the the savant to ask just because i
have a few pencil jordans i like a big
floppy bow because i have sucky ankles i
have what's called flat feet my feet are
not actually flat but that's what they
call it and a big old floppy bow is good
for support but um i actually vary it
depending on the shoe
so
my uh wonderful off-whites here
definitely have my most
elaborate
laces i would say it's because i double
laced them
i'm really specific when i wear them to
make sure that you can see
the text parts on the side that says
shoelaces
but they are yeah they're double laced
um the only thing that i'm really picky
about is i hate it when the laces fold
and then yeah the the second shoe here
orange
so
god i love them
but yeah i mean there's lots of
different stuff that you can do
sometimes it depends on the shoe on the
colors of the shoe um i don't tend to
try to follow any trend but i was really
particular with what i did with these
guys specifically for sure ultimately my
friend
you do you i
am in the camp of people who likes to
wear their shoes i don't care a
tremendous amount about creases uh
there's all this this jargon that anyone
who's not into sneakers won't understand
here i guess but you're like oh no
you're cruising them like yeah because i
like to wear my shoes i like
to have them for the purpose of wearing
them
i do like to wear them tight i lace them
tight because that's better for foot
support
you do you my friend skull robot said
hearing how much you love to write i was
curious how often you read books would
you say you spend as much time gaming as
you do reading does your love skill of
writing effect how you read other
people's works do you have any book
recommendations so yeah i read a lot i
actually haven't been recently because i
mostly was reading on planes
uh because i used to get a plane like
every two weeks so then i would spend
several hours reading anytime i was on a
plane but i also love going to a park on
a weekend and trying to read or going to
the beach and and reading for a few
hours definitely do not do it anywhere
near as much as i game because i play
video games every day um whereas reading
is like once every couple of weeks
it takes me a long time to get through
stuff but i'm a very big fan of fantasy
i really like patrick rothfuss i like
the nine natal trilogy um the wheel of
time series brandon sanderson um a lot
of a lot of the kind of staple i would
say almost
modern fantasy authors not that that the
wheel of time is necessarily in that
bracket these days no my my love skill
of writing doesn't affect how i read
other people's works because i'm
generally only reading things from
really accomplished authors i feel like
if i was reading some something from
somebody who was less accomplished maybe
it would be difficult not to be critical
but i love different writing styles and
i like you know looking at a page and
being inspired by it and thinking oh why
did i like that um because yeah the
authors that i'm reading from are very
good at what they do
game jumper x said alana how did you
come up the outro for your videos
um i don't feel like i have one i just
say goodbye
um so it's very candid there was no
planning
lily mason said what is your favorite
singular episode from a show you love i
absolutely love
the fly episode of breaking bad which as
it stands i think is the best episode um
oh sorry is the best tv show ever made
but i've not seen a lot of other
classics like i haven't seen sopranos i
haven't seen the wire
um but all the ones that i have seen
it is the fly episode of breaking bad
and yeah breaking bad in in general i
think is such a good show um lily also
asks favorite love confession scene i
don't
like writing
romance and i don't care for seeing
romance fictionally
doesn't mean i'm against it but i would
never be able to even tell you
any love confession scenes because i
feel like i just go
like i just
i just it doesn't get me i am kind of a
romantic
in relationships but um
don't care about it in fiction at all i
don't know why miguel osito asked hi
alana i saw you just i saw you just
turned 28. how you feeling about that is
it a weird age i did just turn 28. it is
kind of a weird age because it's like oh
you're officially in your late 20s
you have to have your [ __ ] together but
i feel okay with it because i feel like
i do have my [ __ ] together
like it definitely
feels like an age where it's like oh you
don't get to be like oh you're young
anymore like ah you can make mistakes
whatever like certainly some people feel
that way but i don't see 28 that way i'm
like all right 28.
you gotta you gotta have it down
but i feel like i do have it down i feel
like i have a big girl job i'm not
making dumb internet videos anymore
i mean clearly i am that's why we're all
here but you know i work for one of the
biggest entertainment companies in the
entire world and um it's definitely a
stable position that i'm in and
i have great friends and relationships
across the board and
truthfully i feel like mentally i've
been 30 for like the last six years or
so so it doesn't feel
like a shift like every day that i edge
closer to 30
is like me reaching the age that i'm
supposed to be
i stopped partying when i was 21 you
know i just feel like i grew out of it
real quick so
28 still feels like it's younger than i
actually am in a really weird way like
younger than i am in my head
i think that's maybe because most of my
friends i do have some girlfriends who
are younger but most of my friends are
also
32
35 40 in some cases now as well rodrigo
said what made you change your mind and
decide to apply for a green card i think
one of your previous videos you
mentioned you didn't want to get one or
try to become a us citizen so yeah i um
posted recently that i was nominated for
a couple of awards uh for
an organization called gamers and
last year i declined to be nominated i
said that i didn't want to be nominated
um because i was like i already
i don't really benefit from awards in a
way that smaller creators would or
marginalized creators would it was like
what like take me out of this
this is just like kind of a popularity
contest i don't want
to be a part of it i don't feel like i
am doing anything but taking
opportunities away from other people
this year however i did allow them to
keep me nominated and allowed people to
vote for me because
i'm finally eligible to apply for a
green card um and it is
a thing that helps with the current
green card application process if you're
on an one visa which i am on
they currently care about awards so
frankly when i found that out i was like
oh [ __ ] i probably shouldn't have
declined those awards last year look at
me being a righteous [ __ ] idiot
just hurting myself
that's my bad
so yeah i did i did publicly say that
i'm applying for a green card um but
that's not actually a change of stance i
was always going to apply for a green
card
that is very different to citizenship i
still have no interest in becoming a us
citizen
um i just wasn't eligible to apply for a
green card before january this year i
didn't do it in january because when you
apply for the green card you can't leave
the us until the application process is
like kind of done with i knew i was
going to go home to australia so i
waited until i came back so i've been
actively working on the application
now to try to get through that
it is a lot it is they asked me every
single time that i've ever flown into
the us and for how long i stayed and i'm
like
i don't know how many times i've flown
in and out of this country or when or or
the
all of the dates for that it's yeah it's
definitely a lot the amount of like just
stuff that they need really specific
dates and time stories tremendous but um
yeah definitely nothing changed i was
always going to do that as soon as i was
eligible because living on a visa is so
stressful as is proven by my australian
adventures
um if i run a green card i wouldn't have
had to worry about any of that so i
definitely want the green card
still do not want to be a u.s citizen
i'm good buffetty tough that he said did
you watch bo burnham's inside thoughts
as a content creator yourself i have not
seen bo burnham's inside no
um i know that i should everyone keeps
telling me to but
i just don't watch a lot of stuff right
now i'm planning to watch squid game
that's the plan for this weekend i did
watch all of midnight mass recently um i
mostly if i watch things i watch
documentaries um if i'm being honest but
truthfully i've said this a million
times before i don't watch a lot of tv
because i
play a lot of video games and i work a
lot so i find tv hard to justify because
it doesn't feel productive midnight mass
did feel productive uh the next episode
of idiots and abroad is out
monday
yeah is out on monday and we do speak to
rahul about his role in the show and
about croquet island so you know
definitely something helpful to watch
for that um and to support rahul of
course squid game is video gamey so i
just really want to watch it and
nobody's really spoiled it for me so i'm
very i don't really know what it's about
but i'm super interested in the little
tidbits that i've heard so
very keen to check that out
ian hornback it's an interesting
question what's your favorite icebreaker
mine is what's your favorite disney
movie people's answers can be very
telling of their personality and what
they find important in life my name is
lilo and stitch i don't tend to do a lot
of ice breakers because i'm
pretty anti-social in the grand scheme
of things
um so i don't know that it's an ice
breaker but i question i love asking
people like people i'm friends with
generally someone i already know not
someone i'm trying to break the ice with
is um what's the happiest day of your
life what was the happiest day of your
life and then
you know people their responses are so
interesting people get really
introspective and just go
hmm
and then they think about it and um
you're like just the way they tell the
story of the happiest day of their life
or the happiest moment of their life so
far is is really wonderful
um and yeah if if it feels like it makes
sense i will then ask them about the
saddest day of my life which you know i
don't always want to do that because
that depresses people justin chong said
question i want to get my hair bleached
and died like yours but how do i know if
it's not disallowed by the company that
i work for
i would think you ask
your manager probably lead by example
108 said hi elana slightly unusual
question you mentioned before that you
suffer migraines
uh someone who's starting to suffer from
them more regularly nothing crazy just
once or twice every two months what tips
do you have for dealing with them
so
i only uh get migraines once every two
or three months as well
um and it's only happened for me in the
last two or three years so it's pretty
new
and my genuine answer is that i have
absolutely no tips for dealing with them
anyone who doesn't know this
migraine is not a bad headache it's so
much worse if i get a migraine they just
kind of show up and i'm like oh no
oh i'm getting a migraine and that does
start with what is basically an intense
headache
but then
i will be shaking and vomiting
all day anything that i try to eat i
will throw up migraines it's like being
hungover just i'm gonna vomit every
single thing i try to like i can't even
eat a piece of bread can't eat a banana
the only thing that makes them go away
from me is sleeping
so
the annoying thing about getting a
migraine is that
they show up
generally actually for me it is on a
weekend so it hasn't affected me
work-wise maybe a couple of times um
but they show up and then you're just
like done for eight hours and you can't
do anything but sleep and getting to
sleep is really hard because you have
such a bad headache um and you can't
take pills because you vomit them up so
you're like sitting there in pain you
can't look at any light and you're just
like shaking i usually like slap myself
like if i have one i'm like doing this
while trying to sleep just because
having some other feeling
kind of helps to distract from it they
suck man it's i don't know why i started
getting them i know my aunt does but god
they're garbage
but yeah i don't get them all that often
um i know people get them a lot more
regularly than me
i think that i can tell i'm going to get
one because my eyes start to sting um so
i know i've been trying to pay attention
to that supposedly everybody has a tell
and i think that's what mine is so then
i will take painkillers
as soon as i get
the stinky eyes
doesn't seem to be related to screens at
all though because it can happen when
i'm not even looking at screens but they
[ __ ] suck i just the only thing i can
do is sleep i know caffeine helps but
yeah if i'm too far in i'm just going to
vomit up
even an attempt to drink caffeine or
take a pill or whatever they are
terrible i'm so sorry i hope you're okay
rinkin vibe said if you hadn't gone to
the gaming industry what other career
path would you envision yourself taking
i feel like i've answered this a million
times
um but i'd be a writer so because i'm
already a writer i work in the games
industry i would have just been a writer
in a different field um obviously i've
loved video games since i was like four
it very much
uh it was just a very good partnership
for me because i also loved writing my
whole life but truthfully if i didn't
end up in games i just would have been
writing somewhere else that was it was
quite inevitable i was always going to
end up doing that for sure oh my tapia
said you have a right fiction besides
what you do for your job and if so what
genre and format i write everything
and anything all the time and related to
the last question have since i was a
little girl i've written screenplays and
pilots and books and poems and short
stories
everything ralph hauser said what's a
good way to keep organized and
everything on track you handle so much
career stuff with ease it's wild um
i spoke about this on a stream recently
um
i schedule hard a lot i have a calendar
where i have absolutely everything i
need to do scheduled including streams
sometimes i even put like washing my
hair or going to the gym in there
basically like my whole day is scheduled
so that i know exactly what i have to do
at exactly what time to get through
everything that i need to do
and i do my schedules the night before
generally like if i know things further
in advance i'll schedule further in
advance but
um like i do my youtube upload schedule
is planned a month and a half in advance
i currently have until the middle of
november planned and of course things
will change like depending on if other
things show up if i get busy youtube is
the first thing that i cut back on yeah
very very very aggressive about
scheduling making sure i know what needs
to get done and when and when a certain
thing is due and how long i think it's
going to take and like blocking out my
time to make sure that i don't do other
stuff in that time it helps a lot jmfe95
said are the accessibility awards coming
back this year the combo of you steve
games in education was the best
they are i have been
hard at work on the second year of the
accessibility awards um which is the
award show for anyone who missed it that
i created
last year celebrating um video games
that are doing a great job of making
sure they have a wide array of
accessibility options so more people can
play them and it's a lot of work last
year i wrote produced
host
um fully funded the whole thing myself
and i had steve co-host
um
and i brought on ablegamers to consult
so that we could have actual disabled
players vote on all the games which
we'll be doing again
the the exciting thing about this one is
we are planning to do it in person
um
in january and we're trying to get
sponsors right now to make sure that we
can afford that because that's pretty
expensive but it should be really fun
yeah it's a ton of work but i am excited
to be bringing it back um you can't just
not do something because it's hard when
it comes to particularly talking about
accessibility you know very excited to
bring it back um it should be a lot
flashier this year if all goes according
to plan or it will actually be next year
early next year but it'll be for the
awards for the games that came out this
year
and i hope that you will all watch it
that would be wonderful because it is
a lot
and that is going to be it for this q a
everybody
if you want to ask questions for the
next one it will be all about
video games so you can leave your video
game comments in the section below and i
will um post that sometime in the next
couple of weeks
i will see you guys then bye